[Applause]
i love chris brown
chris brown is chris brown to me is the
most
talented uh
super artist we all right check this out
a lot of people are gonna
not understand well everything you're
about to say i i think i say all the
time about him
but go ahead okay so people are going to
get upset but
suck my suck my dick i don't care the
thing is
we judge the man based on his past and
what he's done and and [ __ ] you
like okay we all make mistakes right
i don't think he as a human being
see like we have legends like the
beatles and stuff like that you know we
have michael jackson
we have legendary artists and i love
that we do have that on earth it's
amazing
but nobody can
last with chris brown in on the dance
floor
or keep up with him musically
or
chris brown will dunk on your favorite
artists and put his balls on their
[ __ ] head
chris brown will outdance them chris
brown will out sing them chris brown
will outdo them
anyway chris brown will [ __ ] your
favorite artist [ __ ]
in front of them and they won't do
nothing the chris brown is one of the
greatest [ __ ] things that's ever
happened
in history of the world on earth this
man
i've seen chris brown float in the air
like float in the air
he's levitating no [ __ ] i'm
being serious i seen chris brown
float in the [ __ ] air with
timberlands on in a bubble jacket
stay in the air for six seconds i've
seen chris brown do things that humans
is not supposed to be doing
chris brown is the most talented person
he's an
alien and something's crazy the fact
that
he's just too good for earth and just
give him his flowers now he's made
mistakes
move the [ __ ] on you know i mean move
the [ __ ] on like
he's made mistakes and we get it but
like stop judging him off for that like
let's talk about what he's bro
so many hits so much [ __ ] that this man
does is so special
and i apologize for getting crazy but
like dude like
he is so talented and it's like people
try to
downplay it as if it's not there it's
like yo bro the sky is [ __ ] blue
and you can tell me it's any color you
want but it's blue but it's [ __ ] blue
you know what i'm saying you got all
these [ __ ] you know the industry is
full of [ __ ] shine
and that's that industry equals [ __ ]
shine what [ __ ] shine it's
all these artists are [ __ ] and they
shine it and they make you believe is
good
chris brown is not [ __ ] shine chris
brown is what happens when you give
money to an actual talent artist
i i always say this about chris brown
he's probably the most talented human
being
that has ever that we've ever seen
because like you said
not only is he the best dancer he could
he could paint a mural on the side of
his house bro
you know what i'm saying like like his
the level of
artistry and talent like you could say
whatever you want about him
but talent-wise there's nobody
we've ever seen that's on his level no
and so i've been seeing like
and no disrespect to drake because drake
is obviously a jedi but like i've been
seeing like a tweet going around that a
fat joe called drake like are michael
jackson i'm like no it's chris brown
chris brown and unfortunately like you
said
there's like a tainted aura still around
chris brown when those conversations
happen but it's
crazy when he is literally the most
talented human being that's probably
ever made music
he can do everything better than
everybody everybody
and he can paint he can
play basketball this dude bro i've seen
that so i've been working with chris
brown on this uh breezy album coming out
and he's incredible and i've never seen
an artist
go in the booth without writing anything
i thought i was the only one who did
that and the only reason why i started
doing that was because i used to work
with nipsey and he taught me that
i had a session with nipsey and i saw he
didn't write and then i started doing
that where i would
say something cut and then punch in and
the way chris brown records
like you know what i'm saying like i'm
not gonna get too deep into topic but
he's just so talented that
it's a shame the world it's a shame how
the world tries to like
downplay it as if like right
like after this interview there's gonna
be people on the comments or people can
be on my tweets on my instagram
bitching at me and it's just gonna be
full of [ __ ] people that are like
got nothing going on in their life and
they're coming at me because of what i
said you know what i'm saying it's a
bunch of those idiots but like
like i just i i just want i i
want to give chris brown his flowers
well he can still smell them and
i just want to continue to do that and i
i want to also say like
as somebody i've been critical of chris
brown's personal decisions throughout
the years
and i'm not even necessarily like the
like i'm a grown ass man so i'm not like
riding around bumping
chris brown a lot of times like i'm not
like the biggest fan of like chris brown
but
you gotta acknowledge he is a alien
bro yeah exactly like exactly can you
not watch this
and you know there was this versus
battle [ __ ] and i'm like
at you know i was thinking like
chris brown versus usher but like breezy
has a bag that like
he could get into that like he can do 60
records
like yo you know what i'm saying like he
could like yo
the features the the like just the rap
and [ __ ] like the versus thing right you
talking about that
yeah like usher's i don't think anybody
could beat chris brown in the verses
but it goes back to what i was saying
maybe drake but
no no no no but i know what i'm saying
that like that might be the
the only like no way but i think i'm
glad that he turned that [ __ ] down
i'm telling you there's no way there's
no way
no drake no nothing nobody nobody could
outbeat
chris brown nobody
from deuces to nobody can now dance
immediately no no
bro i'm just telling you he's incredible
he's incredible like he just floated out
a young thug collab album
bro roll out and go crazy you know just
number one on rape bro
say you love me is one of the most
incredible songs on that project go
crazy is incredible
he continues to make hits he continues
effortlessly it's so light work for him
i i just i just you know we're gonna
move on but chris
i love chris and i think i think he's
incredible and
he's one of my friends and and i'm so
thankful to say he's my face called me
checked up on me during the pandemic
make sure my family's good
right always checks up on me like such a
such a big-hearted person you understand
and he's incredible